voilà des lustres vous allez devoir vous
disais avec les boules de neige ok
l'équipe gagnante
donc tu auras touché toute l'équipe
adverse qu'est ce à choisir a un qui ont
été le meilleur joueur et il sera ici
sur le podium
il recevra un magnifique cadeau pour
jouer avec moi on va voir quelqu un
téléphone qui va pouvoir partir au ski
également voilà je vous le dis et cette
personne
cette personne on l'a eu au téléphone
mais d'abord je vais désigné deux chefs
d'equipe de chef d'équipé
je vais prendre comme chef d'équipé au
point de bernard montiel d'un côté tu
vas voilà qui va symboliser le soleil
sort si et donc il y aura les bonnets
blancs et je vais prendre en chef
d'equipe mon jean luc lemoine jean luc
lemoine ans mais non il est contre toi
d'oublier leurs abonnés merci les bonnes
et réfléchies la côte est le mois où
jean luc jacques au témoin alors
attention bernard montiel qui produit
dans ton équipe
alors les niches et cela est fait pour
ceux qui sont là que vous n'êtes pas
obligé de prendre d'isabelle an dernier
merci maintenant moi isabelle dionne a
alors tendu benjamin benjamin il veut
gagner ici
moi c'est les mineurs sympa ton pote
gilles a gagné bravo pour la coiffure à
agathe agatha ouais ok isabelle label et
et jean-michel été dit bah ouais
l'époque je lis pas choquer ni à huy ha
bah jean michel tabac merci bon les mecs
je pense qu'il sait même pas besoin de
jouer bas donc agir ainsi pourquoi vous
allez vous mettre là bas tiens déroulent
à bab hôtel où m lab à tous
non non les blogs mais qui selon vous
les blancs vous mettez tous vos bonnets
blancs là bas attention à mon top est
chère à mon top on va jouer
vous allez devoir prendre chacun notre
tour une boule de neige d'accord vous
vous mettiez non mais vous devez être
pas être doré bruno labrie alors
attention mettez vous la rentrée
attention les chéris prenez une boule de
neige va démarrer par benjamin castaldi
qui doit tirer ou la laissions attention
chez moi ouais les deux donné des gages
riz paddy gestation on bat bernard
montiel tous hors ue semblent ne veut
pas y aller non j'irai me coucher bébé
d'ici là mais jusqu'où sur toi mais tu
as mis trop de temps
les chinois étaient tous à l'andra et
qu'on arrête les petits gars nov
la tour burj vallet loire les qu'ils
gagnent est venu voir eric avons gagné
l'équipe gagnante venus boire qui nous
fait pour vous a été le meilleur c'était
génial or
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ça va aborder sans tabou
allez allez attention attention vers les
keys pas possible attention que
personnel
[Musique]